[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i'm going to dinner now but it's going
to be a sensible portion so i don't get
all super fat like my dear friend burt
the end
i finished tom score's book today i'd
like to play alone please and in this
video we're going to share some
highlights with you tell you my thoughts
on the book but first please subscribe
to joke world right now if you're a fan
of comedy if you're a fan of tom segura
if you have a good sense of humor if you
don't subscribe right now i assume you
have a terrible sense of humor and you
hope tom dies in a horrible accident you
want them to stop doing stand up
so subscribe it's called i'd like to
play alone please and you find out why
that's the title during the book but it
opened up number two on the new york
times bestsellers list which is pretty
cool for time to be able to do and if
you're looking for like a biography
autobiography about his life he says
this is not what it is it's 224 pages
long broken up into 24 different
chapters and each chapter is about just
a different cool story in his life a
memorable moment in his life yeah this
is not a memoir it's not an
autobiography this is a collection of
stories and essays and it basically
it's an extension of what i do as a
comedian which is i tell stories a lot
it's funny that he doesn't describe it
as an autobiography
or that he went out of his way to say
that it wasn't because although it's not
you know a linear story
of this is where he was born and you
know his career moving forward just the
stories that he does share with you some
are from his childhood some are from
high school you know college age early
comedy late comedy recently you know
being a father like so it does take you
through his whole life just in funny
story form which is pretty cool so you
do get a little bit of a biography about
tom segura from this book i'm also a big
fan of the cover art i think it pops it
stands out and then he has three four
words on the back three other comedians
that wrote a little note about his book
jon stewart ali wong and then joe rogan
this is what joe had to say about the
book and about tom
tom segura is a great guy an amazing
friend and a limitless well of hilarious
stories he has an appreciation for the
absurdity of life that borders on mental
illness this book is a window in his
beautifully [ __ ] up mind where some of
the dumbest people and the ridiculous
things they do take center stage all
masterfully animated by one of the best
stand-up comics on earth he's my
favorite kind of comic because his take
on life is legitimately therapeutic his
enthusiasm for stupid [ __ ] is so
contagious that it actually changes your
mood and convinces you to join him in
his way of seeing it i love him to death
and his book is [ __ ] awesome
that's what joe rogan had to say about
the book and i pretty much agree i mean
besides the personal notes about their
friendship i agree that the book is
[ __ ] awesome
tom also recorded an audio version of
this book that you can purchase and
download and looking back i kind of wish
i would have done that i feel like i
would have got through the book a lot
faster because it would have just
sounded like listening to one of his
podcasts basically him reading these
funny stories you know his voice but the
funny thing about the hardcover is about
actually reading it is while you're
reading these stories and while you're
reading his writing it sounds so much
like him like it's his voice in your
head which is kind of cool you know most
books that you read you haven't heard
the author do thousands of hours of
podcasts and his him talking over and
over so like you know tom's voice and
reading this book every every chapter
comes off as his voice in your head so i
would kind of recommend doing the audio
version i think tom himself said that he
recommends the audio version for podcast
fans but reading it was pretty cool and
i'm happy that i have like the physical
souvenir too now i'm doing the audio
book which is
you don't realize it but it's a
performance like you're actually
performing the original plan is that i
would have to go
to a studio somewhere here in austin or
when i was on the road in la
and i was like nah
i'm just way more comfortable recording
in my own studio like i just you know i
feel
really at ease i look over in the booth
i see you guys who i'm super comfortable
and familiar with and
yeah it just feels like at home so i
think it's i think it's a much better
audio recording because of that as
opposed to being in some space i've
never been to with engineers i don't
know i think it's a it's been a lot
better to be this way
most of the chapters end with a picture
and then he also has a photo essay in
here which is pretty cool some of my
favorite stories from this that you
would probably recognize are like the
wallet story and the mike tyson story
his relationship with mike tyson that's
how he closes the book it's actually one
of the longer chapters and there's
things there's details of the story that
um in this version that you don't hear
about in his on stage version that's
pretty cool to hear about there's also a
chapter about how he started podcasting
about how he started gaining more
tickets on the road and kind of how his
comedy career progressed how he ended up
on netflix just really cool if you're a
fan of tom if you've been following him
for a while or even if you're a new fan
and you want to learn about his his
career in the past definitely recommend
grabbing this book i like the chapters
that he mentions his other friends and
comedy because you kind of get to see
you know behind the scenes of their
relationship and we're a fan of you know
a lot of these guys like ryan sickler
joe rogan burt obviously christina p so
like this is a cool book for just comedy
nerds fans of other comedians that are
in tom's circle as well if you've also
read this book or listened to the
audiobook comment your favorite chapter
for me because i'm very curious to hear
what other people's favorite chapters
are mine was the serena williams one by
a landslide i did not realize how in
depth or how many different parts of
that story there were like i'm not gonna
spoil it for you but that that's
hilarious there are a lot of good funny
stories in this book but
serena williams is my favorite chapter
if you've read the book please comment
what yours was most of these stories in
most of these chapters are about people
that he randomly sat next to on
airplanes like randomly sing next to
celebrities on airplanes and their weird
funny conversations and it's just so why
i get that he flies all the time like
comedians are always flying but it's
just so crazy that he could literally
write a book literally did write a book
just based on like
celebrities that he's randomly sat next
to on airplanes
it's great stuff i definitely recommend
checking it out i am a little bit
surprised though that there's not a
chapter of his most famous legendary
podcast moment of all time that i think
we all can agree on which is this one at
joke world
that's who did it
um and the world is wrld
he cut this for over like four minutes i
love it and he really overlapped your
reactions to like yeah yeah it's so good
but in all seriousness it's a great book
definitely go check it out tom segura
i'd like to play alone please that's it
for this video short book review today
please subscribe to jokeworld follow us
on instagram we'll send you free
stickers i'll see you again monday for
the comedy world news update that we do
every single monday bringing you the
comedy news
[Music]
you